-Chance, it's your turn
right here. Come on, Chance.
-Chance.
-Yeah, top that, Chan-O.
-Let's go, Chance.
-Come on.
-We got a top deck, Chan-O.
-I ain't worried about y'all,
man.
-Ain't worried about nothing.
[ Beeping, audience cheering ]
-Mega Mix!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Mega Mix ♪
♪ Just sing along
with that beat ♪
♪ Mega Mix ♪
♪ Just sing along
with that beat ♪
♪ Mega Mix ♪
-Alright, now this
is a brand-new game.
Let me tell you how it works.
Okay, I'm gonna spin the wheel
and you're gonna get a word,
one word.
Then you're gonna have to sing
a medley of different songs
that have that word
in the title.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
Let's see what word you got.
[ Beeping, audience shouting ]
-"What."
-You got the word "what."
That means you'll be singing
the songs that all have
"what" in the title.
-You got this.
-Okay.
You're gonna have to make
it work over the same beat,
so follow along with the lyrics
as they pop up in front of you,
and we'll see
how well you can keep up.
Good luck.
Chance, take your spot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adam, let's get a beat!
Here we go!
♪♪
-What?
What?!
[ Laughter ]
What?
♪ Turn down for what ♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Turn down for what ♪
-Oh!
-Stay down!
♪ Turn down for what ♪
[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ What's love got to do,
got to with it? ♪
♪ Hey, what's love
but a secondhand emotion? ♪
♪♪
♪ What's love got to do,
got to with it? ♪
♪ Hey, who needs a heart
when a heart can be broke? ♪
♪ I see trees of green ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Red roses too ♪
♪ I see them bloom ♪
♪ For me and you ♪
♪ And I think to myself ♪
♪♪
♪ What a wonderful world ♪
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hey, whatta man, whatta man,
whatta man, whatta man ♪
♪ Whatta man, whatta man ♪
♪ Whatta mighty good man ♪
What's up? Oh, yeah!
♪ Whatta man, whatta man,
whatta man, whatta man ♪
whatta mighty good man ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ What do you mean? ♪
♪ Hey, when you nod your head
yes but you wanna say no ♪
♪ What do you mean? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hey ♪
♪ When you don't want me to
move, but you tell me to go ♪
♪ What do you mean? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?
-Oh, Chance!
-He said, "What?"
-What?
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What?!
-You smoked us on that.
-What?!
That's how you do it! That's
how you do it right there.